By 2040, they estimate 40% of households will be single people.
So, the traditional family is already departed.
State policies are racing to catch up with realities on the ground.
That day can't come fast enough for Masami Onishi.
At home, the 24-year-old single mother handles her two young daughters with ease...
...but she says, it hasn't always been the case.
The single mother works 6 hours a day, 6 days a week just to earn 800 US dollars a month.
The government wants to put more single mothers to work...
...in order to reduce the 50% poverty rate among them.
But, as Ms. Onishi's case shows, it doesn't really help.
Poverty rate of single mothers doesn't change very much...
...even if the mother is working.
Because they have very weak position in the labor market...
...because of the very huge gender gap, wage gap, in Japan.
Doctor Zhou said it's crucial...
...that the government boosts welfare support to single mothers...
...because children raised in poverty aren't likely to escape even when they grow up.
Yasuko Kawabe who started the dining hall for children of single mothers...
...says that's precisely what she's seen over the years...
...and she hopes an alternative route could open up soon.
In an ageing society that desperately needs more future taxpayers,...
...the government needs to help children of single parents...
...become contributing members to society...
...rather than seeing them as a burden and a disgrace.